want to go do Jim Skinner right now the
Collin County Texas Sheriff kind enough
to join us Sheriff um this whole the
drug element offended on everything else
just seems to compound the the tensions
and the crisis building uh have you
gotten any assurances from the
administration at least that part of it
the threat the real drug threat to
Americans they're willing and ready to
respond to
no Neil you can't even get a meeting
with these guys sheriffs in this country
have been trying to meet with the
president for a year and a half and all
we've heard is crickets any Sheriff will
tell you that the situation on the
southern border is an absolute
unmitigated disaster
the drugs trafficked by the cartels
are a tsunami of death crashing in the
United States across this other border
uh it's just simply an epic Slaughter of
Americans taking place and the murder
weapon is fentanyl but the drug cartels
are pushing into absolutely every
community in this country
I'm located in the Dallas Fort Worth
Metroplex in the Northeast quadrant
where the second fastest growing county
in the United States behind Maricopa
County in Arizona and we've had a 571
percent increase in the number of
related deaths since 2019. so wherever
you are watching this program if you'll
get your numbers there you'll find a
similar Trend or worse
so from our perspective
this is just an absolute utter colossal
failure of leadership in Washington and
you had called you had called it a
tsunami a death and that's not too far
off the mark and I I do know that the
homeland security secretary Maracas was
was in your neck of the woods uh in the
last few days he he talked about the the
Havoc that's being wreaked there but he
he was talking about the Texas governor
Greg Abbott and its policy of bussing
migrants or those caught at the border
to cities like Washington and New York
what did you make of that
well I mean this is a it's a great point
right he's making the point for us in
that his priorities are absolutely
backwards listen New Yorkers are great
people and we can't thank them enough
for helping us take some of the pressure
off of these cities along the border
that are completely inundated right now
but the reality is that when you have
the mayor of New York City in Washington
DC complaining about this issue instead
of talking about the real problems real
problem is these drug cartels that are
pushing this fentanyl across that are
murdering Americans well how many of
their folks in New York City and
Washington have perished by fentanyl why
aren't they asking what is the
administration doing right what is the
tripwire what is it going to take for
this Administration to get with the
program and and start putting it
together well we've got suggestions if
you guys will bother to meet with us
and they still haven't
unfortunately not
but listen you know when you talk about
all of these issues you have to ask
yourself when you see as many deaths as
we've seen uh
the President yesterday talked about
tougher sentences for people that were
dealing fentanyl well you know what
that's a great start but you got to do a
lot better than that where where are the
commercials on television every night
and the social media campaigns warning
parents and young people about the
dangers of these knockoff prescription
pills that are embedded you know that
are impregnated with fentanyl what about
funding the crime analyst and and uh the
the badly needed technology that we need
in order to combat uh these drug
traffickers you know here in North Texas
I've teamed up with seven other sheriffs
and we've seized tons of Narcotics
over the last couple of years in
millions of dollars of cartel bulk cash
money and
listen
the government ought to be helping
sheriffs across this entire country
because we all have in common long
distances of open road and when they
moved open to this country they have to
move it across the open road so why
isn't this Administration helping
sheriffs come up with criminal
interdiction units to combat these
traffickers share
that's powerful stuff coming from
someone who's at the front line you
would know better than anyone else thank
you sir for taking the time hi winner
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now